esta clínica de misisipí está en medio
de la decisión del tribunal supremo de
anular el caso roe versus weight en el
caso tous versus jackson la organización
de salud de las mujeres de jackson es el
único proveedor de abortos en el estado
pero tras perder el caso se verá
obligada a cerrar a principios de julio
tras la decisión del tribunal supremo-
trabajadores médicos acudieron a la
clínica donde los manifestantes
antiabortistas celebraban el fin del
derecho constitucional al aborto
eeuu no está preparado para lo que está
a punto de suceder con la caída de raw
no lo está las mujeres van a ser
criminalizadas las personas que buscan
abortos van a ser criminalizadas y han
destrozado literalmente la constitución
a causa del aborto la clínica dijo que
intentará proporcionar abortos a los
pacientes que lo necesiten durante el
período de tiempo legalmente permitido
pero algunas clínicas en eeuu se vieron
obligadas a cerrar inmediatamente como
en luisiana donde cerraron las tres
clínicas que practicaban la interrupción
del embarazo en el estado
la reacción visceral es que van a morir
más mujeres en luisiana por esto estas
historias son reales nos preocupa
realmente que las mujeres intenten
hacerse daño si quieres buscar un aborto
el estado más cercano es illinois no
mucha gente va a poder volar hasta nuevo
méxico california o nueva york
la organización sin fines de lucro
plantar en hood dice que sus puertas
están abiertas a las mujeres que buscan
el precedente en los estados donde sigue
siendo legal como california washington
y nueva york
con más de dos tercios de los
estadounidenses a favor de mantener la
sentencia roe versus wade 1973 el apoya
el aborto en eeuu nunca ha sido tan alto